[Música]
una agenda estratégica con un alto
componente en materia medioambiental el
canciller Alemán olace estuvo de gira
por América del Sur una visita que sirve
para reforzar esos estrechos lazos con
la región de América Latina también
marcar posiciones estratégicas a nivel
geopolítico pero sobre todo ganarle a
China en la búsqueda para obtener litio
esto es en su esfuerzo por acelerar la
transición energética y también dejar de
depender de Rusia en esa materia las
principales naciones desarrolladas a
nivel mundial están compitiendo por
recursos por accesos a metales y a
tierras raras muchas de ellas están
disponibles en América Latina por
ejemplo en chile que es el segundo mayor
proveedor de litio después de Australia
por eso la relación entre Alemania y
chile es de suma importancia para Berlín
veamos
el presidente boric y yo hemos
conversado también sobre el acuerdo de
asociación entre chile y la Unión
Europea este convenio se realizó en
diciembre del 2022 en Bruselas con el
acuerdo marcamos la Pauta para futuros
acuerdos comerciales modernos y
ambiciosos la visita del canciller
shorts También sirve para reactivar no
solo estos asuntos que están pendientes
entre Alemania y la región de América
Latina o por lo menos estos tres países
de América del Sur también para
reactivar los temas que hay entre la
Unión Europea y el mercosur una deuda
pendiente entre ambos bloques veamos
ambos coincidimos en que la
profundización de nuestras relaciones
comerciales alberga un enorme potencial
claro
que el acuerdo Unión Europea mercosur
tiene una especial importancia para ello
y ahora Nuestro objetivo es llegar por
fin a una rápida conclusión de las
inversiones y el tema de medio ambiente
por supuesto es sumamente importante
para Esta visita a su paso por Brasil el
canciller Alemán también realizó allí o
relanzó allí el fondo amazonía que está
constituido desde el año 2008 por
Alemania y Noruega pero fue suspendido
en el año 2019 por decisión del
expresidente Jairo bolsonaro se trata de
un paquete de ayuda de 35 millones de
euros para fortalecer dicho fondo para
proteger la selva del Amazonas y también
la etnia llanomani que enfrenta graves
problemas en cuanto a materia sanitaria
entonces Alemania tomará ventaja ante
china en su búsqueda por recursos
naturales en América Latina Más allá de
la explotación de recursos que
beneficios puede traer entonces para la
región fortalecer los nexos con Alemania
y el balance que se puede hacer de la
relación entre la Unión Europea por un
lado y América Latina por el otro cómo
hacer frente a la presencia de china en
el terreno también Y aprovechar el
espacio que ha dejado Estados Unidos en
la región de América Latina lo vamos a
analizar en unos minutos aquí en el
debate de France 24 para conversar sobre
este tema hemos invitado a Marcus Daniel
Mayer él es analista internacional ESPN
también es docente del departamento de
derecho constitucional de la Universidad
externado de Colombia que está ubicada
en la ciudad de Bogotá y también está
con nosotros Oliver dalihauls director
de la fundación Freddy's evert espero
haberlo pronunciado bien en mi alemán a
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de esta discusión
pueden dejar todos los comentarios
preguntas y comentarios de lo que
vayamos hablando aquí a lo largo del
programa a través de las redes sociales
ya lo saben estamos en Twitter estamos
en Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba franz24_s@
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta se
la recuerdo numeral el debate f24 todo
junto para que dejen los comentarios no
se olviden también que los contenidos
del programa también están disponibles
en Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y
en TuneIn
Bueno pues comenzamos con nuestros
invitados aquí en el estudio de France
24 le doy entonces la bienvenida a
Daniel Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí acompañándonos en el estudio y
pregunta para El Punto de partida llega
tarde Alemania a América Latina ante la
presencia de China y el terreno que ha
dejado Estados Unidos bienvenido gracias
por la invitación y yo tenía que sonreír
un poco porque hay una un dicho muy
famoso de Thomas
autor alemán que dijo los alemanes
siempre llegan tarde y se refería a
compartir el mundo entre Inglaterra
Francia España más o menos y los
alemanes llegaron muy tarde y no
sucedieron Entonces tal vez se puede
subir esto en este contexto un poco
porque nuestra historia de colonización
es muy corta y no tiene ningún contexto
con América Latina otro que Inglaterra
con Estados Unidos Nosotros con España
Francia también presente Portugal
entonces
históricamente llegamos algo tarde y por
esto faltó también un poco en inglés
porque la pregunta era qué puedo ofrecer
América Latina para nosotros es lejos
culturalmente estamos cerca más cerca
que Arabia tal vez África pero
no no hay necesidad de intercambiar
económicamente especialmente y esto sí
ha cambiado dramáticamente en los
últimos meses por la guerra en Ucrania
porque
lo que antes ofreció especialmente
Brasil y Argentina era carne y trigo
y la Unión Europea dijo especialmente
Francia No gracias no hay demanda Y
ahora Estamos en dos puntos nuevos
Ucrania que era muy importante para
agricultura para África por ejemplo pero
también para Europa está a riesgo y
nosotros nos despertamos y vimos las
cosas no son tan seguros como parecieron
claro entonces la posición de Argentina
Brasil es mucho más fuerte que antes y
más todavía yo creo es en el sector
energético
Nosotros sí entonces ahí quedamos con
algunos puntos sobre la mesa ya vamos a
profundizar sobre ellos Quiero
preguntarle a Oliver Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
y también el mismo Punto de partida
llega tarde Alemania o llega en un
momento coyuntural en el que puede
todavía sacar provecho ambas partes de
esa relación histórica con América
Latina el viaje tiene en el momento
oportuno desde hace muchos décadas
Alemania tiene
relaciones diplomáticas económicas
políticas con América Latina y también
con Colombia y El canciller no viene por
la primera vez en la región como
canciller Sí pero viene en el momento
oportuno para fortalecer exactamente las
relaciones que tenemos desde hace mucho
tiempo
vienen básicamente desde Alemania a
buscar recursos naturales en Chile en
Brasil en Argentina reforzar también
esos lazos históricos y comerciales que
hay entre las partes que puede sacar de
beneficio América Latina de esa relación
Oliver cuando bueno vienen interesados
en recursos como el litio también en
proteger la amazonía como lo estábamos
mencionando Pero qué puede sacar de
provecho América Latina que no es una
economía tan planificada como lo es la
Alemania que están pensando a futuro las
relaciones económicas son importantes
para Alemania para Europa para los
países de la región y
Alemania puede ofrecer sostenibilidad y
también
mucho experiencia y compartir esta
experiencia con los países de la región
me parece
importante y eso también es un una
ventaja de las relaciones en general con
Alemania por este lado Daniel su opinión
que puede sacar de ventaja América
Latina
pues América Latina es una posición
mucho más fuerte que antes porque tiene
dos cosas que son vital en este momento
primero es el litio es un
material clave para la movilidad del
siglo XXI y
el segundo es gas hay un campo de gas el
segundo más grande del mundo que se
llama vaca muerta en Argentina y antes
era muy costoso porque hay que presionar
este gas el link para liquidarlo
transportarlo hasta ropa eran demasiado
costoso y lo compramos en Rusia con un
tubo pues este tubo no exista más
Entonces si estamos dependiendo de
Argentina vende este gas O ropa y
entonces las cartas están mixtas de
nuevo parece Sí en ese en ese orden de
ideas y les pregunto qué puede ganar
América Latina porque claramente la
relación con china es una relación que
por lo menos desde el punto de vista
América Latina es gana gana ellos
extraen recursos naturales llevan de
aquí alimentos y productos elaborados en
América Latina pero América Latina
recibe inversión en infraestructura por
ejemplo es un poco la misma fórmula que
están implementando en África pero
Alemania viene dispuesta aquí a invertir
a hacer otro tipo de negociaciones no
solamente beneficiarse en la extracción
del gas y de combustibles para para El
Siglo 21 como lo ve usted Oliver
Colombia Brasil Argentina Chile países
democráticos como Alemania como la Unión
Europea tenemos esos intereses comunes
defender la democracia defender los
derechos humanos y eso también tiene que
ver con las relaciones en general y
otros países mencionados no tienen eso a
ofrecer y eso me parece un punto clave
en nuestras relaciones
Daniel por este lado impresiones sobre
sobre ese esa fórmula China de de venir
a ofrecer a ayudar a construir
infraestructura Alemania Cómo puede
competir contra eso Por ejemplo
Bueno yo creo es geográficamente muy
lejos latinoamérica de Europa pero culto
realmente estamos como acabo de decir
Oliver muy cercanos ahora Estamos
democracias hablamos un idioma europeo
tenemos una historia compartida por
muchos siglos y entonces yo creo
es mucho más fácil
generar confianza y todas esas cosas
políticas que son la base
valores compartidos para hacer negocios
y para
vivir más cerca en el futuro por decirlo
así
yo creo también hay un punto más
político en esto que es la geopolítica
obviamente Porque
si miramos o ropa es al este del
Atlántico y el Atlántico es no hay gran
conflicto en Atlántico tenemos la otan
tenemos muy pacificar esto mientras El
Pacífico es una región
geoestratégicamente
no inquieto en el momento pero ya vemos
que China y Estados Unidos van a
competir en el futuro sobre el dominio
del Pacífico
Ojalá que sea en pasos pacíficos y
económicos regulados y en este contexto
obviamente América Latina y Suramérica
tendrá un rol clave porque chile
obviamente tiene 4,000 km de Costa con
el Pacífico en Brasil y Argentina
también son entre estos dos océanos y yo
creo esto también es un señal que
olafelds está enviando que dice hoy ropa
está dispuesto de Buscar aliados y
alianzas afuera
de la otan y del pacto Atlántico eso a
mí me parece claro aquí hay un punto
importante y es esa negociación de el
mercosur que está empantanada desde hace
muchos meses por cambios de gobiernos en
América Latina enfoques distintos
también defendiendo intereses al
interior de la Unión Europea caso muy
particular lo hablábamos fuera de
cámaras el de los el campesinado francés
y las zonas Rurales francesas que
generan ahí controversia y pues algunas
discrepancias con el interés que tiene
el bloque en general
se habló del mercosur se habla de la
importancia del mercosur pero en esencia
el mercosur está casi en una fase
agónica es un es un vale la pena para la
Unión Europea
firmar un tratado con un bloque que
incluso no se está moviendo al ritmo que
debería moverse Oliver por este lado
vamos a ver el desarrollo en el mercosur
pero el el objetivo del canciller es
exactamente
empezar de nuevo esta negociación y ver
el desarrollo para la Unión Europea para
Alemania
un contrato justo para responder a las
preguntas sociales
es importante y ojalá el contrato de
mercosur
por este lado que qué piensan
yo leí el statements en Argentina y me
sorprendió dos cosas mencionó me costó
varias veces eso solamente se hace si no
es una vaca muerta porque mencionarlo
porque haya años y el otro es que
expresó varias veces estamos partnerales
a la misma altura ustedes no son
digamos entre comillas de ese mundo y
que necesitan pero nosotros le
necesitamos y vamos a negociar nuevo y
muy en serio y dijo yo quiero que este
documento se firme pronto que ese
problema de
detrás de mercosur hay dos países que
están mucho en favor en un momento
Alemania por las razones mencionados y
España también por hacer casos nexos
obviamente y dos en contra eso es
Francia para proteger proteger su
campesinato y Polonia
pues la el ímpetus la voluntad política
de empujar me acusó en contra de Francia
no era muy grande porque Alemania eligió
porque provocar los franceses para esta
cosa que es muy ajeno no tiene mucho
peso para nosotros como he dicho esto es
muy muy diferente Ahora es urgente la
cosa con el litio y con el gas Entonces
yo estoy casi seguro con una cosa que es
coincidencial pero muy podría ser
decidido decisivo en el momento
y esta cosa es que España cerra
presidente de la Unión Europea en la
segunda mitad de 2023 y obviamente
tienes la oportunidad de mover las cosas
más fácilmente siendo presidente
Entonces yo estoy casi seguro que van a
firmarlo junto y pues que Francia va
a ponerlo quién sabe no está poniendo en
riesgo esa ya fría relación que hay
entre París y Berlín
es un ingrediente más para seguir
distanciando a maco de de
No lo sé exactamente pero la confianza
entre
nuestros países entre América Latina y
Europa es una realidad hay estudios
también apoyando por la fundación ibat
que lo dicen la confianza entre los
países existe Y eso es el base para el
futuro y eso me parece importante y en
Daniel aquí no no sé no se distancian
eso Porque además Son son dos países
fundamentales dentro de la Unión Europea
después del retiro del Reino Unido
Francia de Alemania prácticamente han
llegado como a tomar el liderazgo pero
también se suma hay un capítulo y es la
salida de Ángela Merkel que era como la
gran líder de la Unión Europea y ahora
hay una disputa entre París y Berlín en
cierta forma esto no incrementa también
esa Esa diferencia pues como he dicho
las cartas están otra vez con la gran
Ucrania yo creo es una cosa que hay que
realizar estamos hablando en términos
que antes no hubo geopolítica dominancia
en el Pacífico en el Atlántico eso eran
categorías de siglo 20 temprano pero
esos son las realidades Entonces
sí hay que mirar que las relaciones
Alemania y Francia dentro de la Unión
Europea no se rompen pero yo creo sí se
notó por ejemplo muy claramente que el
presidente fue recibido con muchos
Sonoras en Washington y
[Música]
yo estoy seguro que detrás de las
puertas cerradas hay mucho que negociar
en el momento pero obviamente es muy
importante no romper con esto y es
natural Angela que quedó en
office 16 años y tiene una posición muy
fuerte que podría ser que Francia suma
más
en la Unión Europea porque obviamente
solts tiene diferentes
enfoques ahora también hay que recordar
de la persona
pero también tiene su biografía su
histórica o la frase de Hamburgo es de
una familia de emprendedores Y
negociantes entonces él es muy
no es ideólogo él está haciendo lo mejor
para su negocio que es la la República
alemana y o ropa en el momento Qué hay
que decir eso un motor económico de la
Unión Europea también si le va bien a
Alemania le va bien a la a la Unión
Europea y se mueve también la economía
de muchos países de Europa central que
que tienen estrechos nexos económicos no
solamente por la Unión Europea sino pues
porque son países que hacen parte de la
misma cadena de producción alemana y
también porque pues es un país que es su
naturaleza ser un país exportador pero
ahí en donde donde uno mira entonces las
dos caras de Alemania con una intención
de acercarse y exportar y mejorar la
relación con América Latina Pero veo una
Francia que de pronto le cuesta hacer
ese balance de defender los intereses de
el área rural francesa por los intereses
de la Unión Europea Ese es el debate
que Me permito el problema también es
este proteccionismo como sabemos en la
economía ha prevenido que la campesinato
francesa adapte al mercado globalizado Y
eso es un problema y yo creo también
podría ser un chance para decir hay que
modernizar esta cultura agrícola
francesa que es muy valiosa muy
importante pero no pueden vivir por
siempre por medio de protección del
mercado global yo creo eso es algo que
se va a discutir también especialmente
frente a países como Argentina y Brasil
que tienen condiciones naturales mucho
más favorable para la producción
agrícola
es algo natural hablamos al inicio del
programa de la importancia para Alemania
de hacerse con estas reservas de litio
la importancia de la relación con chile
que es el segundo
productor de de litio en el mundo tiene
grandes reservas en su territorio el
tema de la transición energética qué tan
importante es para la agenda al interior
de Alemania en este momento no solamente
por el contexto de la guerra y de la
situación actual sino de en el tema
político es un tema que domina la agenda
como Cómo se está viendo ese tema el
interior del país
[Música]
energética tiene una gran importancia en
el debate actual Pero tenemos también
un consensos los partidos políticos
están de acuerdo
sobre esta transformación
algunos quieren lo hacer un poco más
rápido otros son poco más lentos pero el
consensos está
creado en Alemania y
claro necesitamos también el apoyo de
otros países y por eso Colombia y la
región tienen una importancia y como
marcha ese proceso de transición va
marchando a buen ritmo la guerra
significó una barrera un un bache en el
camino importante o Alemania sigue
marchando hacia esa transición a buena
marcha como la analiza usted sí me
parece estamos en el bueno y por este
lado Daniel Pues yo no soy tan político
ni idealista yo creo hay que mirar que
detrás de esto el clima es muy
importante obviamente yo no estoy
volando ver esto pero el tema también es
el acceso de los animales y sus carros
que son como el de la economía alemana y
europea en gran medida al mercado gringo
los los carros americanos no se venden
perdieron en la conexión tecnológica con
esto y bajo Trump decidieron decir bueno
llamémoslo protección contra el cambio
climático pero a partir de unos pocos
años no vamos a dejar motores de
combustión nosotros exigimos cero
emisión y para cumplir con esto en el
mercado americano donde empiezan ambos
desde cero con carros eléctricos eso es
de Vital importancia en una posición
mucho más débil que antes porque Europa
y Japón eran líderes en este sector para
competir en el mercado americano
necesitamos acceso a este litio a mucha
energía y rápido y no solamente por los
productos por los productos que exporta
Alemania bueno la industria Automotriz
toda la conocemos ya usted lo mencionaba
Daniel pero que hay a nivel político de
esta transición hay acuerdo entre las
entre la industria alemana en hacer
rápida esta transición porque vemos que
por ejemplo la industria Automotriz se
quedó un poco atrás si lo comparamos por
ejemplo con china que está invadiendo
los mercados claro y es mucho más rápido
construir un carro eléctrico que de
combustible entonces pero de mis
contactos en la industria esto es en
pleno Progreso Sí incluso otra cosa el
reducir el Pues eso no tiene mucho
grueso pero reducir el nivel individual
y hacer otro Magic driving con GPS y
tener carros eléctricos que no requieren
un conductor individual pero son
interconectados electrónicamente
entonces hay una Revolución en frente
que será muy muy fuerte y los alemanes
están preparándose pero los gringos
también y los chinos la competencia es
muy difícil aquí entonces en toda esta
competencia a nivel comercial vuelvo y
pongo empieza a América Latina Más allá
del litio Entonces qué más podemos
ofrecer nosotros nos estamos quedando
atrás a nivel tecnológico tal vez
América Latina se está volviendo
simplemente una región que provee
recursos provee materias raras tierras
raras pero a nivel tecnológico que hay
del desarrollo
la el intercambio entre los estudiantes
por ejemplo de latinoamérica y Alemania
en este sentido Tiene un gran
importancia eso es el futuro de nuestras
relaciones hay muchos estudiantes ahora
que quieren estudiar en Europa en
Alemania Y eso va a ayudarnos en la
creación de buenas relaciones en la
futuro aparte de todos otros otras
preguntas Sí el tema es que tanto de
esos de esas personas preparadas en
Alemania que han estudiado en Alemania
puedan venir acá a aplicar ese
conocimiento para aporte para la región
claramente si hacemos esta comparación
la región está mucho más atrás a nivel
tecnológico con respecto a a regiones
pues como Europa china bueno Estados
Unidos obviamente pues ni se diga ahí es
cuando entonces también uno puede pensar
bueno Por qué se en América Latina para
esta apuesta y no en África por ejemplo
que está al lado o la presencia china en
África ya es muy grande usted cómo lo ve
Daniel pues como he dicho todos están
jugando en África también África tiene
una población muy creciente mientras
nosotros estamos en un continente
incluso Colombia Sudamérica que está en
declive demográficamente y China también
entonces son muchos factores que
influencian en esto pero china
definitivamente está muy activo aquí en
Latinoamérica Alemania China
Alemania le teme a China
a nivel geopolítico Qué tal Yo creo que
no yo creo los Estados Unidos y eso es
una manzana de discordia entre Estados
Unidos en Europa en un momento China
para Europa es muy lejos para Estados
Unidos es muy cerca y la guerra en
Ucrania todos esos sí enviamos estos
sistemas O sí Y no y con el tubo en el
Báltico con para el gas todo esto es
parte de la negociación Para qué es la
otan es Atlántico o son los basales de
Estados Unidos para que puedan actuar
todavía más fuertes esto es una cosa que
se han que también se negocia con todo
esto incluso con la visita Bueno hay que
decirlo hay que decir lo que Alemania
también tiene grandes inversiones en
China volvemos al tema Automotriz hay
grandes plantas de las automotrices
alemanas trabajando en China desde hace
ya muchísimo tiempo hay una relación muy
cercana no es una relación de miedo pero
tienen en Alemania también la visión que
hay en Washington de temor que este
régimen
este tipo de gobierno que está en China
ha mostrado ser exitoso económicamente
esto compite con el con la como con la
oferta o la propuesta que hace la Unión
Europea basada en derechos humanos en
democracia en el ciudadano como el eje
central hay temor a eso a que de pronto
China expanda o no
una vez más este viaje tiene una
importancia para Alemania Para
diversificar nuestras relaciones con
países democráticos que quieren defender
los derechos humanos y responder a las
preguntas sociales que tienen una
importancia en nuestros países y me
parece el gobierno del canciller pero
también
de los gobiernos
progresistas en América Latina tienen
respuestas y la conexión entre
nuestros continentes
puede
continuar a responderlo hago la pregunta
porque sí hay un temor en Washington por
ejemplo en Estados Unidos país de
importancia en nuestra región a que este
modelo se imponga por encima de la
oferta Que ellos hacen
Pues como analista siempre sí escucho
derechos humanos y yo creo estamos muy
lejos en esto Yo escucho diferencias
políticas
y yo creo Estados Unidos y Europa están
bastante diferentes no en su defensa ni
ni con América Latina en su defensa
de los derechos del ciudadano de
derechos humanos de liberalismo
pero en la postura frente a una
dominancia política de China para ropa
eso es una cosa que tiene mucho menos
amenaza Estados Unidos Australia Nueva
Zelanda Japón Correa Canadá incluso
América Latina Tal vez un día y entonces
yo creo estamos más relajado en estos y
pues Mientras nos producen estos partos
para los carros que vamos a sembrar aquí
a un precio justo y barato pues no nos
gusta todas esas violaciones de Derechos
Humanos pero no nos concierne
directamente políticamente yo creo que
eso es una gran diferencia nuevamente
entre Estados Unidos y Europa ven la
perspectiva de Europa Pues bueno son
grandes economías que se la están
jugando por la región de América Latina
todo esto con un con un foco un interés
en el tema ambiental y energético
Alemania punta general el 80% de su
demanda eléctrica de energía renovables
y por eso esta gran apuesta que están
haciendo en la región de América Latina
esto también entonces también poniéndome
aquí un poco en el en el punto de de
teoría conspiración también le marca un
poco de terreno a Francia en la región
Francia el presidente no ha venido a
América Latina ha sido reelegido Hace
algunos meses tiene el chance de
apostarle de pronto a América Latina
hacer una visita en esta en esta región
a lo largo de este segundo mandato Pero
aquí ya ya Alemania por lo menos ha
puesto un pie en tres países importantes
de la región de América Latina qué
análisis pueden hacer ustedes de eso
quién responde primero Oliver
toma ventaja en la región
no no lo sé
lo siento y por este lado Daniel Pues yo
lo vería pero no lo he analizado en
detalle pero la visita de macron era muy
muy exitoso y yo podría imaginar que es
un signo de sí Mira ya y las tensiones
entre Alemania por el tubo están más
pronunciados entonces podría ser que en
este contexto se dice pues viajemos
eso es pura especulación Sí por eso
decía estoy entrando aquí en un tema de
un poco de de
paranoia política pero pero son temas
interesantes es interesante vale la pena
en este contexto en el que estamos en el
que hay tanta atención a nivel
internacional pues ya me quedan pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero entonces que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que deja Esta visita
del canciller por América Latina un
primer punto de contacto entre Alemania
de América la desde que Olaf shorts
asumió la la cancillería de Alemania y
una visita importante para la región
balance lo bueno y lo que tal vez queda
pendiente de esa visita el balance que
se puede hacer comienzo por Oliver por
este lado otra vez este viaje me parece
importante para establecer las
relaciones políticas y defender nuestras
democracias el enemigo en Europa de la
Democracia viene de la extrema derecha
lo hemos visto también en Brasil hace
algunas semanas esta
este consensos entre los países
democráticos me parece un objetivo muy
muy importante en este en esta guerra
del canciller aparte de todas las
preguntas económicas entendimientos a
nivel democrático entendimiento entre
democracias podemos concluirlo así y
Daniel por este lado su conclusión para
el cierre yo creo pues no tengo la bola
de vídeo no sabemos y visitas y
declaraciones es una cosa y lo que pasa
después la otra pero mirándolo adentro
de la situación actual de los conflictos
que vivimos en un momento la guerra el
cambio climático de todos estos yo creo
Es algo que es histórico en el sentido
Alemania claramente Busca nuevos
alinearios afuera de la Unión Europea y
yo creo es va más allá de La retórica
política pero sí quieren fortalecer los
lazos con esta región y Esto va a
beneficiar obviamente Colombia un día en
algún momento también habrá algunos
avances un poco más al norte de la
región hay muchos países que tienen
relación histórica con Alemania no
solamente chile
Argentina y Brasil Colombia como ya
usted lo menciona también México entra
en este en este escenario que tiene una
relación mucho más cercana con Estados
Unidos pero también le importa mucho el
mercado de la Unión Europea Pues a los
dos les agradezco por haber aquí con
nosotros haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia de Francia veinticuatro ya
veremos Entonces los frutos de esa
visita del canciller schulz América
Latina y cómo se fortalecen las
relaciones entre las partes Es todo por
hoy En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos los
comentarios preguntas que quieran hacer
A través de las redes sociales estaremos
atentos para leerlas y responderlas en
su debido momento Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros sigan con France 24
[Música]